i can't believe this is my job right now
i'm barrel and for this episode of
around the world i'm trying something a
little different
a few weeks ago i made this story about
noodles
and in it i said i'm not doing instant
noodles that is a whole other episode
and if you want that one let me know
turns out you wanted that episode
so i had to think
i couldn't film in a noodle factory and
it also didn't seem that interesting to
film in a noodle factory
but
i had a kind of fun idea
i asked on youtube how you guys liked to
prepare instant noodles where you lived
and the response
was crazy
totally crazy
so i went through the responses and i
picked out eight that i wanted to try
myself
i went shopping
and i'm going to prepare eight of your
recipes from eight countries to see the
different ways that people prepare
instant noodles around the world
so this
is the instant noodle episode
[Music]
the first noodle dish we're trying is
from brazil
it's a simple recipe two ingredients
instant noodles and soft cheese so i'm
gonna boil the noodles
once they're ready
drain most of the water
add the seasoning packet
add some of the soft cheese stir stir
stir
and done
[Music]
okay so this is kind of like a tomatoey
cheesy
it's really good
the noodles are really good they kind of
remind me of top ramen noodles
the tomato flavor is really interesting
i've never had that one before
and the cheese is like
it doesn't taste like any cheese i've
ever had before
what does it taste like
[Music]
it's like really
savory
this one's really great the ingredients
were not so easy to come by in u.s but i
found them
this next recipe came from nigeria it
uses indomie noodles onions tomatoes
peppers and
they recommended an egg on top
so
just chop up all the vegetables
cook them
boil the noodles
add the flavoring
combine them all
and top with the egg
this one looks really good
kind of have to
break the yoga
totally different flavor than the last
noodle dish
and it is really good
it's like a very springy noodle
i like the simplicity of this recipe
a little spicy very creamy
the onions are great
peppers great tomatoes grapes
the egg yolk
[Music]
it makes it creamier they said you could
add it or don't add it who doesn't want
to add an egg and this is a totally
totally satisfying dish
this next dish comes from italy
there's chicken flavored instant noodles
a can of tuna cheese tomato avocado and
soy sauce so you're gonna boil the
noodles
drain most of the water add the flavor
packet add the cheese a can of drained
tuna fish and then top it with avocado
tomato and lastly a bit of soy sauce
this one was the most work so far a lot
of ingredients i actually really had to
follow the recipe
it smells really good it's totally
different than anything i would ever
think to do with instant noodles
okay
the soy sauce is actually a really nice
touch on top it's got like an
interesting saltiness
it's funny it's totally growing on me
it's definitely got a heaviness and the
tomatoes do a really good job of
lightening that between the cheese and
the tuna and just you know the pasta
it's funny because in the person's note
they said trust me it's delicious
they're right
[Music]
this submission came from nepal and it's
why my noodles with onion tomato ginger
lime juice and green chili you're gonna
mash up the noodles
[Music]
cut up your vegetables
put them in a bowl
add the noodles to the bowl put in some
lime juice add the seasoning packet and
you're done
[Music]
okay
this is the first instant noodle dish
that did not require any cooking which
i'm pretty excited about
[Music]
there's a freaking kick
i'm sweating
the tomato is nice it helps break down
the spice a little bit the lime juice
definitely a plus
more than just softening the noodles it
definitely helps a little bit with the
heat
adding the green chili on top of the
spice packet that was a bold move
i'm really sweating
i feel this would be really good with a
beer
it looks really
good i like it
this recipe was a submission from
trinidad and tobago
for this one i needed spicy instant
noodles so i just added sriracha kfc
fried chicken and bok choy take the skin
off the chicken and cook it so i put it
in my air fryer
take the meat off of the bones your
hands are going to get really greasy put
that in a pot with the flavor packet
and some water
let it boil add the bok choy stems cook
them for a bit add the leafy part cook
that for a bit and then add the noodles
put it in a bowl and then you're gonna
top it
with the crispy chicken skin
fabulous
i mean
this one's pretty extra it's also
beautiful
right
wow
honestly though that crispy chicken skim
is a game changer
i'm not even kidding if you serve me
this in a restaurant i would be like
yeah this tastes great
is that what fried chicken does
the noodles are chopped ramen had them
before i think adding the sriracha
totally worked to make it spicy because
it's got a kick
[Music]
also having the big pieces of chicken in
here is a delight
this is like elevated
chicken soup the soft noodles you have
the leafy greens the crunchy chicken
there's just like
it's a party
glad i got invited
this recipe was submitted from indonesia
you need indomie noodles a bit of flour
egg scallion onion
cheese
and chicken stock powder
you're gonna cook the noodles
rinse them in cold water add the
seasoning packet to the noodles
chop up the vegetables add the egg and
the flour and the chicken stock
mix it all together
don't pay so much attention to the
monitor that you spill all the noodles
and have to start again
make little pancakes fry them
and then top with a bit of melted cheese
well this one was definitely a lot of
work
that is an absolute delight
it's silty and it's crispy and it's soft
i love the idea of taking instant
noodles and making these pancakes
the big chunks of onion in it are really
great the noodles just become a part of
the batter almost
and the cheese is great on top like it's
fun but you don't need it either i think
i might eat one more
i'm just gonna finish up
all right
this recipe was submitted from india
so for this dish you need maggi tomatoes
onions peppers a little bit of ghee and
paneer
put some ghee in the pan
add the vegetables
add the chopped paneer
a little bit of salt
cover it
then you're going to add the noodles and
some water
cook it uncovered
and you're done
okay
this one smells really good
hot
the flavoring for these noodles
totally different flavor than any of the
other noodles i've tried
there's a similar base between this and
the nigerian dish
but i cooked it with a little bit of
ghee
and so that adds a nice little flavor
kick and then the paneer is really nice
it's chewy and it's creamy
and these noodles are very bouncy
that's a good bite
and the maggie flavoring is just really
good
in the great debate of why my noodles
versus maggie noodles i feel like these
are two totally different noodles
the noodles taste totally different i
wouldn't necessarily compare them
[Music]
and this last recipe is a submission
from singapore
it uses ramyan
cheese egg milk scallion and chili
flakes start by cooking the noodles in
milk
add some cheese
add the flavor packets add the chili
flakes
and then you're gonna crack an egg and
cover the pot
garnish with scallions
[Music]
all right
this one smells luxurious
okay there's a lot to unpack here
this recipe is instantly comforting the
flavor packet for this is spicy but then
the cheese and the egg combine
to make it really creamy i've never
cooked noodles in milk before wow
game changer really good when you crack
the egg in here the egg white kind of
cooks inside the noodles so you get
these pockets of egg white which is
really fun
man if i had known this recipe in
college
i would have been a happy happy student
wow
this was such an amazing week not only
were your dishes delicious but they were
inventive
i knew that instant noodles were a
universal food but i had no idea how
customizable they could be
and seeing all the recipes from around
the world just really opened my mind
i'm gonna put a link below so that you
can see the thread and look through all
the other recipes because i highly
recommend you try some of them i'm
obviously gonna also include the recipes
that i cooked in the description
and if you have any other recipes please
leave them in the comments because i'm
converted i want to try more of them now
i also really enjoyed this experience of
trying these different foods here at my
house because it shows that all of these
dishes are attainable you don't have to
necessarily travel to those countries to
get a taste of them
so maybe i'll try it again i don't know
what do you think is there another food
i should do this with that's kind of all
i got
go try some of those noodle dishes you
will not be disappointed i promise
[Music]